solo a Star Wars story isn't set to fly
into cinemas until May 25th but a
handful of lucky movie lovers got to
board the Millennium Falcon ahead of
time for a journey to a galaxy far far
away the latest entry in the sprawling
Star Wars franchise solo had its world
premiere May 10th in Los Angeles and
those who attended the star-studded
events have taken to social media to
spill their spoiler-free thoughts on the
ron howard directed standalone film
indieWIRE film atatürk a turbulent
rights it takes a bit for it to find its
feet and for old and Ehrenreich to turn
on enough charm to make you forget he's
not Harrison Ford but once it kicks into
its hey let's make a crew in yes also do
a height stuff it totally flies herbal
and also gushed about Donald Glover's to
light for performance as young Lando
Calrissian and praised Phoebe wallet
bridge who voices Lando droid companion
l 337 yahoo entertainment senior
correspondent kevin Palau II felt much
the same writing that while urban rugs
performances excellent l-3 a surreal
scene stealer Paulo he also noted how
the film's overall tone which is lighter
in comparison twas mostly serious
predecessors works wits advantage solo a
Star Wars story is really good fun as
hell it's a straight intergalactic heist
movie kind of refreshing to see a Star
Wars movie without the Death Star or the
rebellions fate at stake Alden
Ehrenreich is super impressive as Han
but L three might be my favorite new
character Ong Jhon of Mashable echoed
their sentiments while also giving a
sweet shouts out to Tandy Newton's ball
Alden Ehrenreich is the real deal Tandy
Newton is who I want to be when I grow
up and Phoebe Waller bridges l3 well
we'll talk about that later
Mike Ryan senior entertainment writer at
up rocks caught out the first half of
the film as hit and miss clunky but say
is once the high splutters in full swing
it's a whole lot of fun
Wyatt also calls Donald clevis Lando
legit fantastic and in perhaps the most
intriguing reveal about the film so far
says it's not really hiding the fact
that setting up more Han Solo movies
cinema blends Eric Eisenberg was even
less enthused sharing one of the few not
quite negative but not positively the
reactions thus far solo a Star Wars
story is fine its flow to find its
footing but picks up in the second act
it is definitely fun has the occasional
prequel problem answering questions I'd
need answers too but also some fun
references overall I liked it didn't
love it off that lukewarm response to
solo there's a flurry of wonderful words
from slash film head Peters caretta who
praised the film for its portrayal of
young Han Solo and for its unexpected
twists so there was a blast
screenwriters Jonathan and Lawrence
Kasdan nailed a character han Solo
yes the story is a series of expected
events but none of them happen as
expected stay away from spoilers big
Marvel levels that will make you wonder
where Lucasfilm is headed next score
etta concludes that the finished product
more than makes up for the production
troubles a project faced including the
firing of original directors Phil Lord
and Christopher Miller regardless of any
of the production problems the finished
film is going to make most fans happy
fans can decide for themselves how solo
a Star Wars story backs up when the film
hits theaters on May 25th thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love doing
[Music]